géographie aujourd'hui comment localiser
un lieu donc cette vidéo se base sur la
fiche technique numéro 5
comment localiser un lieu où localiser
un lieu cette fiche technique et
distribué vous sera distribué aux cours
mais est également disponible sur le blu
géo donc n'hésitez pas à l'imprimé
directement je me base évidemment sur un
référentiel qui est proposée par le flec
et qui donne des trucs et astuces pour
localiser a lieu alors on va expliciter
cette fiche technique par un exercice
pourra faire ensemble ici en direct
on va se poser d'abord une question
quelles cultures vivrières et pratiquer
à bangalore alors une petite explication
sur cette question cultures vivrières
bas ce sont les cultures qui nous
permettent de nous nourrir et bangalore
c'est une ville en inde nous qu'on voit
ici déjà que sur le premier document qui
est proposé mais j'ai les différents
types de cultures vivrières le riz le
blé et le millet qui sont évidemment
répartis d'une certaine façon en
fonction du climat en fonction du relief
on va voir des cultures différentes et
nous ce qu'on veut savoir c'est à
bangalore
quelle culture et g commençons tout
d'abord par la localisation absolue donc
ce sont les coordonnées géographiques
qui me sont fournis ici on me dit que
bengalore est situé à 12° 58 minutes
nord de latitude donc on va dire 13
degrés et 77 34 de longitude est
alors je ne vais pas commencer à
chercher ici sans savoir où je veux
aller je vais regarder ses coordonnées
elles sont justement mentionner ici je
vois qu'ici je suis un nuage étude de 70
ici et longitude de 80 la latitude de 15
bombes 13 je vais être un peu en dessous
et je vais être ici plutôt vers le 80
aux deux tiers disons-nous à la voilà
dans le gall or et la voyez que avec les
coordonnées géographiques
c'est très rapide très direct donc je
sais plus où moins oussou vous bangalore
pas je le sais très précisément sur sept
quartiers mais sur deux
endroit si je pouvais retrouver ça
facilement et bien voilà on a perdu
bangalore parce que sur la deuxième
carte ou là je vais pouvoir voir où se
situent les différentes cultures
vivrières ben je n'ai que quatre villes
qui sont mentionnés delissio nord
calcules tu calcutta ici à l'est bombay
à l'ouest et madras un peu plus au sud
bien que bangalore ça va être plus ou
moins ici mais je vais utiliser un
repère pour mieux localiser bangalore il
faut donc situer bangalore par rapport
aux repères et je vais prendre comme
repères j'ai pas grand chose j'ai quatre
villes ici bas je vais prendre celle qui
est la plus proche
enfin la ville de madras je vais tourner
sur notre cas de regarder madras madras
et ici et bengalore est juste là donc je
vois que bang alors si je trace une
ligne comme ceci je vais prendre une
autre couleur le trace une ligne on voit
que bangalore est un peu en dessous de
m'adresse sur la même ligne au centre
vraiment quasi à égale distance des
côtes ici et ici
donc grâce à ces informations nous dire
que je dois être plus ou moins au même
niveau que madras mais que je suis
vraiment au milieu des terres je veux
pouvoir dire que bangalore et sans doute
ici si tu es localiser ici évidemment je
ne sais pas être plus précis
mais le deuxième document c'est un
schéma cartographiques
donc c'est une vision simplifie mais je
vois que ici je peux directement
répondre à ma question il me dira que
bangalore a pour principales cultures
vivrières le millet qui est une céréale
alors on va compliquer un peu la chose
imaginons maintenant que j'ai une image
satellite type google earth
comment je fais maintenant pour
localiser bangalore parce qu'ici j'ai
même perdu madras alors ici sur une
image satellite je vais devoir me fier
aux formes à la morphologie à ce qui
apparaît à l'écran
je mets deux cartes côte à côte et je
vais toujours me référer à madras parce
que madras et sur les côtés là les côtes
s'est découpé je vais pouvoir voir leur
forme et donc madras est ici et je vois
que d'abord j'ai un
une zone du littoral qui est plus ou
moins rectiligne et puis j'ai une espèce
de petite boursouflure il faut et après
ça re diminue comme ça je vais retrouver
sa seule et mâcha d'élite en me disant
que madras et au niveau justement de
cette boursouflure je vais faire la même
chose avec voile amazon plus ou moins
avec t il voici la boursouflure et puis
après ça diminue donc je vais pouvoir
dire que madras se situe plus ou moins
ici donc si je garde la même logique
je vais être assez maligne attention mon
image satellite est un peu de travers
donc jeune femme aline un peu un peu de
travers aussi et dont je pourrais dire
que bangalore est sans doute situé ici
voilà évidemment je ne peux pas être
plus précis mais disons que je ne serai
pas loin de la réalité
voilà maintenant je peux vous proposer
d'autres exercices
ici vous avez 4 vue du nord de mons de
la ville de monde
vous avez d'abord une image une
photographie aérienne c'est la première
le premier cliché à l'échelle de 1 10
millièmes
le second cliché c'est la même échelle
on est toujours au 1 10 millièmes
donc là vous avez une carte
topographique le troisième cliché c'est
une carte topographique aux 20 millièmes
et le dernier est la dernière projection
c'est une carte routière la hausse en
millièmes donc j'ai des échelles
différentes et j'ai des types de
documents un peu différent ce que je
vous propose par exemple c'est de
choisir un élément et de leur trouver
sur les autres sur les autres vues alors
par exemple vous pouvez commencer par
quelque chose très facile de prendre par
exemple la gare ou en tout cas ici le
réseau de voies ferrées qui est ici
c'est pas vraiment la guerre mais en
tout cas c'est un défaut voilà je le
retrouve là je le retrouve ici
et puis ici ça va être un petit peu plus
difficiles ben voilà ça va se trouver
plus ou moins l'avant l'écartement et
vous pouvez faire une série d'exercices
comme celui là pour vous aider à
localiser de plus en plus vite une fois
qu'on a acquis le truc ça devient très
bas
si l'on trouve très facilement les
différents éléments vous choisissez par
exemple si vous avez le grand large ou
vous choisissez d'autres de l'autre
point vous pouvez choisir ici je crois
que ce sont des usines qui sont ici ou
en tout cas les bâtiments qu'ils soient
ici et puis après vous essayez de les
retrouver sur les différentes cartes
dans le grand atlas vous avez également
différentes projections qui vous sont
proposés et là vous pouvez faire le même
type d'exercice voilà ben je vous
souhaite un bon travail n'hésitez pas à
me contacter si vous avez d'autres
questions et à bientôt